jeff younger is a business owner in
texas and now a candidate running for
the texas house of representatives you
may recognize his name if you follow a
select few conservative media outlets
anyway because he's been uh locked in a
years-long custody battle with his wife
anne georgeless
now the center of this dispute is their
now nine-year-old son james anne says
that james is really a girl and uh and
she wants to transition him you know she
found out that james really has a girl
magically trapped inside him and so she
wants to
do the transition in fact she has long
since begun the so-called
social transition dressing him in girl's
clothes
giving him a girl's name luna
now jeff fiercely opposes this plan as
any sane and loving parent would and has
been fighting for custody so that he can
prevent the further psychological and
physical abuse of his boy
ultimately jeff lost the fight
tragically and the courts handed custody
over to mommy munchausen so jeff is now
running for office because he realizes
that the only way to save his son now is
to see to it that childhood gender
transitions are legally outlawed
completely
now to that end
as we talked about last week texas has
gone part of the way the governor
recently declared that the medical
transition of minors is child abuse
under state law under already existing
state law and any adult participating in
or facilitating the practice should be
arrested and charged that's a that's a
good step but it's an important step
but as long as this barbarity is not
officially and specifically outlawed it
will still happen
the governor can only do so much on his
own the aclu is sued to block abbott's
directive from going into effect because
of course the aclu cares deeply about
protecting the right of adults to
butcher drug and castrate children what
this means most likely is that the whole
matter will be tied up in the courts for
the foreseeable future
the texas legislature has to act and
that's what jeff younger is calling for
and that's why he is running for office
and it's also why he held an event at
the university of north texas last night
to discuss this issue and explain why in
his view
child transition should be criminalized
now the event drew controversy from the
moment it was announced
and uh when flyers started going up
around the campus last week
uh last week the president of the
university neil smatresk
responded to complaints over the flyers
by condemning them the flyers not the
complaints as intolerant
in a campus-wide email he said quote i
know the last several days may have felt
particularly difficult for the
transgender members of our community due
to the intolerant views of a handful of
campus members we have a variety of
resources through our division of
inclusion diversity equity and access to
support you during your time at unt and
we hope to offer you a safe place to
heal and grow your support system
so
the president university after scooping
the lgbt complainers up in his arms
patting them on the back swaddling them
assuring them that everything will be
okay the poor babies he did finally
affirm though the right of jeff younger
to come and say his peace
but he also accused younger of quote
challenging the very existence of trans
people
so the stage was set the irrational
beliefs and attitudes of the radical
lgbt leftist leftists had been affirmed
and legitimized
and that led directly to what happened
last night
younger
came to give his talk as scheduled
and all hell broke broke loose in quite
a literal sense in fact
as many of the protesters appeared to be
demonically possessed outside of the
event an enormous pitchfork mob
assembled demanding that the event be
shut down we have some of that footage
let's watch that
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so you see a pretty good crowd
there but they didn't settle for
remaining outside
if they had just done that then you know
whatever but they flooded into the room
and shut the event down themselves
inside preventing younger from
presenting his case
and they did that by chanting and
screaming at him the entire time listen
to this
you can practically smell that room from
here
truly a collection of the greasiest and
foulest ugliest humans you're likely to
ever come across
and they weren't satisfied to keep their
tantrum purely verbal at one point in
response to younger misgendering someone
in the audience i.e gendering them
accurately
somebody stood up on the desk and spat
on him watch
she
[Music]
hey
i just hope jeff got his rabies shot
that's all i can say
now
when i watch all this unfold
a few things come immediately to mind
first of all
modern college leftists are apparently
going to barbers who use weed whackers
and chainsaws they go to like the
landscaper to get their haircut
the worst haircuts i've ever seen all in
one room
more importantly um i may have to pay a
visit to this school you know bullies
like this should not get what they want
what they want is to make sure that
nobody who opposes them ever shows up on
their campus again they're trying to
send a message
what they ought to get instead then is
you know me
if you're affiliated with the
conservative group on campus there
please reach out to me maybe we can set
something up
most importantly of all though i think
our three points
now first of all to echo something that
our very own god king jeremy boring
posted this morning in response to this
you are a fool
if you pay to send your kids to college
you are paying paying exorbitant
back-breaking sums
to have your children turned into that
you're paying to have them brainwashed
you are sending them into the most
expensive cult commune in history where
their mind and soul will be eaten and
inside the shell that was once your
child will be placed a blue-haired
lunatic beholden to a world view so
irrational and fragile that he'll melt
into a puddle if somebody even so much
as mentions in his presence that men
have penises and women have vaginas you
are paying for that
you are asking for that to happen
you are going into debt to make that
happen to your kid
now sure there are some exceptions there
are a few good schools left in the
country a few
and there are plenty of kids who go into
these environments and they come out
with their minds and souls somehow still
intact i meet students like that all the
time at my events but the odds are
stacked against them
and most
are destroyed by the experience
it's just not worth the risk
it's not close to worth it
it's definitely not worth paying 100 000
for
two notice that when i outline the
horrors of the modern university system
i do not say that the kids who graduate
from these institutions can't get jobs
that's not one of the things that i list
now it's true that a lot of them indeed
cannot get jobs but we make a mistake
when we point to all the tantruming
tantruming
gender studies majors in that room and
scoff and just assure ourselves that
well the real world will catch up with
them
they're going to be unemployed living in
their mom's basements rejected by
society
certainly that will be the case for some
of them certainly it should be the case
for all of them
but it's not the case for all of them
not even most of them
the scary thing is that in fact they do
get jobs
the real world will not catch up with
them
i hate to say it
because they are going out and
redefining the real world
we are living in a culture in a country
increasingly shaped by people like that
those kids in that room
that's your next generation of teachers
those are university professors
those are human resource managers
at fortune 500 companies
those are diversity consultants
they'll take their blue hair over to a
nearby middle school and help to keep
this self-perpetuating cycle of crazy
going
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated